hi i'm claudia and today i'm making my
chocolatey version of one of tasty's
most popular videos banana bread bottom
cheesecake i'm not taking this recipe on
my own i'll have help from alexa on the
amazon echo show that now has tasty
step-by-step recipes
alexa show me banana bread bottom
cheesecake from tasty
okay for banana bread bottom cheesecake
here's a recipe from tasty
alexa start the recipe okay i'll read
the directions one step at a time at any
time you can ask me to move to the next
step
alexa next step
in a large bowl mash the bananas with a
fork i love recipes with banana you
always have bananas that are about to go
bad and this is a perfect example of
something to do with your nanners
alexa how much vanilla do i need the
recipe calls for one teaspoon vanilla
extract alexa is helping me not miss a
thing
[Music]
this is where i'm making my first tweak
on this recipe by adding cocoa powder to
give the base of this cheesecake a
chocolaty twist
the chocolate plays really well with
banana so it makes sense the chocolate
banana would make a happy marriage in
this recipe
i've always wondered how many calories
are in this let me ask alexa alexa how
many calories are in one cup of
chocolate
one cup of chocolate has 886 calories
alexa continue recipe
pour the banana bread batter into a
greased nine inch 22 centimeters
springform pan the echo show is
incredibly convenient i love how
you can have your hands messy in the
kitchen and you can still use it
bake for 30 to 40 minutes or until the
top is set alexa set a timer for 40
minutes 40 minutes starting now
alexa next step
in a large bowl add the cream cheese
sugar and vanilla
i've always loved using alexa products
to play music i didn't usually use my
alexa to cook and this is opening my
eyes to the possibilities
alexa how many tablespoons are in
three-fourths of a cup
0.75 cups is 12 tablespoons great i
could only find a tablespoon so this
helps with the chocolate i'll go ahead
and melt it in the microwave
i love chocolate it brings so much extra
flavor to a dish i wonder if alexa has a
joke about chocolate alexa tell me a
joke about chocolate how do you win over
a chocolate lover
keep some twix up your sleeves it's
pretty good alexa
i think this recipe is definitely a
crowd pleaser i would definitely bring
it to some get together with friends
maybe as a sort of me to the parents
kind of gift i think it would start me
off on the right foot
i love following tasty recipes but i
always seem to misplace my phone or my
hands are messy and it's hard to stop
and pause just tell her to go to the
next step i can start from the beginning
i can pause and start without dirting up
my screen
chill for three hours or overnight
alexa save recipe
recipe saved
alexa what's your favorite cake
there's nothing better than birthday
cake
unmold the cheesecake
then slice
and serve drizzled with caramel sauce
[Music]
last step enjoy
[Music]
make your favorite tasty recipe with the
help of alexa